welcome to world stories
residents of Venice find themselves
priced out of the property market
Canada's First Nations protest against
aquaculture but we begin in Germany
after last week's election the AFD of
far-right party has its first seats in
the Bundestag we visited the hora Valley
long considered a stronghold of the
Social Democrats the city of Essen is
this politician's hometown but since the
German election
karl-heinz End was shut a Social
Democrat says he doesn't recognize it
anymore in the past his party usually
won an easy majority but this time just
28% many of Angela scheitz neighbors
told him in advance that they were
voting for the far-right AFD party
instead of his people tell me they come
from a family that's always voted SPD
but they went with the far-right because
they felt we needed to wake up we have
to win back our voters if we just sit
around and wait for four years that's
not going to happen and we shud is at
pains to find out how to get his
constituents back in his camp at least
the blue-collar contingent in his
neighborhood pub he runs into supporters
of the far-right I would have voted for
the AFT too but you know what I threw
away my ballot the police they don't
even have the nerve to drive to the main
station anymore
rising crime rates 11% unemployment and
a migrant population of 40% and all that
in a city that's run out of money and
has few resources to solve its problems
that's how analysts are explaining the
Social Democrats stronghold turning to
the AFD but this area in the Ruhr Valley
has long been known for its successful
integration of hundreds of thousands of
migrant workers once known as guest
workers decades ago and an anti-racism
gathering in Essen a diverse crowd
watches performers sing out against the
far-right many in the migrant community
have expressed growing concerns since
the election
unstyled people from the AFD will try
and stop such events from happening
there'll be a lot of tension and that
tension will have a negative effect on
our day to day interactions this was the
moment of the AF DS triumph as Sunday's
election results were announced
[Music]
Haggard poiseuille a newly minted AFD
politician likes to replay this scene on
his computer he used to be a teacher and
vote SPD but he says he felt the party
wasn't addressing his concerns anymore
he couldn't speak his mind about
Chancellor Merkel's open-door refugee
policy he insists he's no racist he was
an instructor for children with migrant
backgrounds for years but he agrees with
the AF DS position that Germany should
stop a turning for its Nazi past every
time a German tries to show even the
smallest measure of patriotism someone
takes out a swastika and beats him over
the head with it
then came the TV news report that
members of the AFD Parliamentary Group
have already started bickering Pagla
cell is speechless and he begins to
wonder if the party will even last four
years
karl-heinz Anka shot is holding out hope
for better times for his Social
Democratic Party since the election
Essen is not like it used to be
Canadian salmon is popular here in
Europe the market is booming but not
everyone is happy among Canada's First
Nations opposition to aquaculture on the
country's west coast is growing charisa
glendale is a member of the nagas nation
and indigenous people from the west
coast of canada she's now fighting
against industrial fish farms like this
one which raised hundreds of thousands
of salmon in the region Glendale and
other demonstrators have set up camp in
the middle of this farm and they say
they've occupied it they want to send a
clear message
let them destroy our environment take
our salmon away from us work done these
guys need to get off the occupied
facility was built by Norwegian company
Marine Harvest the largest salmon
farming firm in the world it has sales
of around three and a half billion euros
a year company representatives refused
to speak with us the industry is
profiting from Canada's new trade
agreement with the EU which has gotten
rid of tariffs and increased production
and exports but environmental activists
say aquaculture is damaging wild stocks
of fish when they migrate upstream from
the Pacific to reproduce they swim right
past the fish farms and critics say that
has spread disease and infection
Canadian authorities however played down
the issue and say the caged salmon posed
no threat to their wild cousins when
Atlantic salmon are actually put out
into the ocean they go disease-free
they're raised in hatcheries the
land-based facilities and freshwater and
we actually have a large suite of
vaccinations that are given to the fish
to guarantee that they're entering the
water in a clean and healthy way
that may be true but why are fishermen
and British Columbia catchment fewer and
fewer wild salmon many factors could be
playing a role not least climate change
or pollution but most locals blame the
fish farms for their empty lines and
nets the First Nations activists are
planning to continue to protest the
industrial agriculture facilities in
their waters and say their rights are
being violated even the Coast Guard is
now involved and there's no end to the
impasse in sight
the namja say the only solution is for
the fish farm to shut down
Venice is a dream destination for many
tourists but its residents are being
squeezed out by rising prices now local
activists are determined to limit the
damage done by Airbnb and offer
alternatives Venice a dream destination
for millions of tourists but for local
residents it's become more of a
nightmare
the crowds descend year-round to walk
across the famous bridges and see the
sights and wittingly they're squeezing
locals out it's becoming increasingly
difficult for Venetians to live in their
city of canals right now in this moment
I think to be the only variation in here
I am like a stranger Sachi belongs to a
group of activists they're campaigning
for affordable housing for Venetians the
properties of their owners of the houses
prefer to give the houses to all the
tourists because they earn much very
much money than to rent a house 12
additional family short-term tourist
rentals attacks at the same rate as
long-term let's Airbnb for example is
booming here the platform offers more
than 5,000 apartments rented out
regularly to mainly young visitors we
came from Barcelona exactly and we
stayed in Airbnb for just one night the
hotel industry is also alarmed it's
trying to exert pressure on the city's
government the aim is not to ban private
rentals but implement restrictions
lanata propose their commitment we
suggest limiting the duration of rentals
to 90 120 or 150 days people shouldn't
be allowed to let their properties to
tourists the whole year that's when it
stops being a side earner and becomes a
commercial business Ally and one that's
enjoyed by many foreign companies to the
answer though is not to vilify guests
says Emanuela del Carlo but to instead
support local Venetians he's part of an
international network called fair BnB
its aim is to provide an alternative
rental platform that benefits both
locals and tourists alike who's gonna
spend money with us knows that the
person is giving money is a resident and
a great part of the commission that we
will win held is gonna be rain they
stood in like childr school problems to
restoration of buildings arts and stuff
like that
fair B&B is still in its early stages
next year the platform will go online if
successful it will be doing its bit to
ensure that the city of canals is not
just in the hands of foreign investors
and tourists
the global beauty trade is a
billion-dollar industry cosmetics health
the hair industry in Africa particularly
the demand for hair extensions and wigs
is booming this report from Nairobi Dan
Dora is one of Africa's biggest trash
heaps but what's a cast-off for some is
a treasure for others
thousands of Kenyans make their
livelihoods from trash like Winnie
Wanjiru she specializes in hair both
synthetic and real salmonella there are
many different types of hair if you're
lucky you might find undyed human hair
someone may have bought it but not liked
it and chucked it away the boys from the
dump sell them to me for the equivalent
of two u.s. dollars and I then sell them
to a salon for around five US dollars
not a bad profit margin for the 31 year
old but competition is tough at the dump
she's not the only one keen to make
money with hair here at the market in
one of Nairobi's poorer areas the hair
pieces are sorted and cleaned oiled and
combed like many other hair stylists
Mary when GQ buys the hair from the
rubbish dump and then prepares it for
her customers they pay a fraction of
what they would in top salons so feel
free fun we like these pieces because
they're cheap and come from nearby
instead of those from the central
business district that are expensive and
far away by the time they arrive the
customer has left this woman doesn't
mind that her new adornment wants lay on
the trash pile as long as it's properly
restored looks good and the price is
right she's just one of many benefiting
from this form of recycling
[Music]
you